what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the most recent happenings in
the seven deadly sins story including
the physical and emotional showdown
between Zell drous and his daddy the
demon king it what seems to be a major
turning point in the story a turning
point that could be the beginning of the
end of the entire series I will be
breaking down everything that happened
and everything that we know so far right
here in this video and if you enjoyed
these types of videos and you'd like to
see more please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications and you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest 7 Deadly
Sins news and updates including the
latest updates on the new anime season
finally this video will of course
include manga spoilers we're dealing
with the latest developments in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned chapter 2 - 9 starts
off with the demon king attempting to
distract celtris with yet more illusions
inside the spirit world he wants to play
off of zelgius big brother issues by
showing the scene in which meliodas told
zell drous that he was leaving the demon
clan this was a very emotional moment in
the lives of both brothers because
meliodas asked zelgius to take gelda and
come with him but Zell just refused and
he told Mellie Otis that he no longer
considers him a brother and that the
next time they meet it will be as
enemies but the demon king then has the
Meletus illusion say things that the
real meliodas did not say including that
he never considered zelgius his little
brother and that he will gladly kill him
the next time that they meet the demon
king is trying to convince algae's that
this is the true nature of Melly Otis
this is what he was really up to the
whole time but zelgius doesn't buy it
Zell giuse lashes away at the demon
Kings illusion and exposes the demon
king in his true body which towers over
Zell drusen gelda zelgius says that he
remembers this specific exchange with
meliodas very well and he knows that
Melly Otis was speaking from his heart
the only one who was not speaking from
his heart was
eldress because his heart wasn't really
with the demon king in the demon clans
war against the goddesses the demon king
says that zelgius cannot understand how
painful of this for him to have to kill
his own beloved sons he wanted them to
go down the right path the path of the
demon king but they chose to abandon the
ideals of the demon king and give
themselves over to petty emotions such
as their love for Elizabeth and gelda
zelgius responds by saying that calling
them his beloved sons now is a joke
since he never loved them and they never
loved him either they never had a good
relationship which means that even
before meliodas decided to leave the
demon clan both Mele Otis and zelgius
had a strained relationship with their
father zelgius also says that even
though he knows that he isn't as strong
as meliodas and the demon king he is
going to do his best to fight the demon
king because this is a spirit world and
in here zelgius has a chance of winning
just like meliodas managed to win back
when the demon king was possessing his
body
Celes is determined to return to gelda
his beloved back in the physical world
and now that she has finally been freed
and they have a chance to be together
zel giuse is committed to winning and he
will never give up until he finds his
way out the demon king then proclaims
that he would never lose to such a
pathetic and weak mind and man who is
chained to a woman but zelgius tells him
that he will never understand that love
and affection for others can grant a
person powers beyond what he can imagine
here's Elvises talking about the idea
that when you have something to fight
for when you are fighting for someone
who is important to you you can find the
kind of inner strength within yourself
that you would never be able to access
otherwise in anime and manga we have
definitely seen this a lot the dreaded
power of friendship and how when their
friends are in danger anime characters
and especially anime protagonists can
suddenly gain insane power-ups and
defeat much more powerful opponents and
of course dec who's ten billion percent
smash comes to mind but to be fair in
the real world there is such a thing as
hysterical strength which is the concept
that in certain emergency situations and
especially when their loved ones are in
danger humans can gain a burst of
superhuman strength and even
the entire cars by themselves in order
to save someone trapped underneath so
there is some real-world basis for these
power of friendship power-ups but of
course in anime this concept is always
combined with magical steroids at this
point I also want to bring everyone's
attention to how often the demon king
mark smelly Otis and zell dress for
being in love with women in this chapter
in particular he calls them pathetic and
weak minded because they are chained
down to a woman but he has also made
many mocking statements in the past
about the fact the malleolus and zelgius
fell in love and are willing to make
important decisions based on their love
for Elizabeth and gelda it really makes
you wonder about whether there is some
history between the demon king and a
woman that left him feeling heartbroken
betrayed and completely jaded when it
comes to love and relationships a lot of
people have theorized that perhaps at
some point in the distant past the demon
king and the supreme deity had a
romantic relationship but for some
reason it didn't work out and this
lovers quarrel is what sparked the holy
war in the first place we actually still
don't know how exactly the holy war
started so it isn't out of the realm of
possibility that the supreme deity and
the demon king may have had something
going on as the only to outright divine
male and female characters in the series
although we still don't know hardly
anything about the supreme deities so it
really is just pure speculation until we
get more information about her feel free
to let me know what you guys think down
in the comments
was there some spicy romance and drama
going on between the supreme deity and
the demon king and then eventually some
petty lover's quarrel caused at the holy
war or do you think that something else
caused the holy war and if so what do
you think it was let me know down below
I also thought it was pretty funny that
while he was having this emotional
discussion with the demon king where he
was defending the power of love Zell
just kept telling gelda not to tell
Melly auras what he is saying
I guess that even though zelgius is very
different from his father and even
though he has changed and developed over
the years he is still embarrassed to
openly talk about his feelings in front
of his older brother there are
definitely some older brother issues
happening there and I mean I get it as
an older brother myself I imagine that
it must be hard for younger brothers to
constantly live in our glorious shadow
always
looking up to us and admiring our
greatness from afar I am sure that my
younger brother goes and will agree with
me on this one now let's just hope he
doesn't actually watch this video now at
this point Zell just does something very
clever he begins to play mind games with
the demon king by taunting him and
pouncing on his biggest weakness which
is his ego Zell just tells the demon
king that his pride has been shattered
and his mind has been weakened by his
previous defeat at the hands of Mele
auras back when the demon king had tried
to possess melioidosis body and then
Zell dress really goes for the jugular
by suggesting that the demon king was
defeated by the very emotions that he
considers to be weak and pathetic as
predicted this infuriates the demon king
and he tells ljus that he will never be
able to escape from this spirit realm on
his own but zelgius just smirks and says
that his brother meliodas will
definitely come for him implying that
together the seven deadly sins and
zelgius and gelda will succeed in
defeating the demon king just as he was
successfully defeated when he tried to
possess the body of melio das the demon
king tells eldress to stop behaving this
way after all wasn't he the one who
wanted to become the next demon king to
succeed his father on the throne and
lead the demons to victory in the holy
war but SEL just tells his father and he
is mistaken the celtris didn't want to
become the next demon king because he
wanted to follow in the footsteps of his
father rather he wanted to become the
next demon king so that he could take
down his father and rule in a way that
is completely different from the way
that the demon king has been ruling by
the way if you're interested in the life
of Zell dress and his true goals and
motivations you can check out my video
called the tragic life of zeldron in
that video I went into great detail
explaining what SEL just really wanted
and how he wanted to become the next
demon king so that he could become a
better ruler than his father and create
a better world for the demons under his
command he was even willing to sacrifice
his life for the cause and in my opinion
zelgius is the unsung hero of the demons
to us he was introduced as a villain but
in reality he always wanted to stop his
father's ruthlessness and become a
better ruler for the entire underworld
and he wanted to make it so that the
demons vampires and all the other
creatures of the underworld
could live together in peace zel jizz
then proceeds to use his signature move
ominous nebulae against the demon king
and this seems to be highly effective
the demon king's body breaks down inside
the spirit world and as the battle
against the seven deadly sins rages on
the outside the demon king appears
visibly injured even in the physical
world in fact gelda suddenly returns to
her physical body and then on the final
page of the chapter we see that the Ten
Commandments are being detached from the
physical body of zeldron
the text on the final chapter says that
the demon Kings oppression is severed by
trust and love and zelgius is freed from
his father's grasp this strongly implies
that the battle might actually be over
gelda is back in her physical body and
zelgius is seemingly regaining control
of his own body without a vessel in the
physical realm we could assume that the
demon king will again be banished to
purgatory and he will have no way of
opposing zelgius and the sins but the
demon king and nakami Tsuzuki have
fooled us in the past
in the next chapter chapter 330 is
called he holds on so this could
definitely be referring to the demon
king and the fact that he somehow
manages to hold on despite the events of
this chapter if this is the case and the
demon king still isn't defeated then we
can assume that the battle will now be
taking place entirely in the physical
world with Zell drizelda Elizabeth and
the seven deadly sins all there in one
place whatever happens I'm sure this
will be one epic battle and I'm still
waiting for the mother of chaos King
Arthur and perhaps the supreme deity to
make an appearance at some point during
this story so I'm not going to put my
money on the story being over yet feel
free to give me your thoughts down below
is it finally over are we heading for
another quote unquote epilogue or are
there more twists and turns still ahead
if you enjoyed this video please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't make sure to select the option to
turn on
all notifications you will still miss a
lot of our uploads that's just the way
that YouTube works in 2019 you can also
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
anime out Pro to keep up with all the
latest developments here on the channel
and also on the latest news about the
seven deadly sins including the new
season of the anime I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime out pro
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King's eldest on hell
cruise stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat a karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki TJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam Mary Mack makoto-kun and your voice
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]